here's a cloud tip I wish I knew when I
was starting out did you know Google
cloud has a library of quick starts
tutorials and interactive walkthroughs
online I used to think that in order to
learn I needed to be in a library or
working for my home desktop but I found
a lot of Joy recently and learning new
things during my commute in a cafe or
even a fun New part of the office that
I've discovered these interactive
resources are a great way to go beyond
the documentation and try things out for
yourself check out the link in our
description to see our entire library of
Google Cloud Quick starts and tutorials
and make sure to subscribe for more
Cloud tips